Speaker 1: in light of the anti vaccine problem
that we have in the United States, which may
well prevent us from really getting past this
pandemic, there are now more and more people
calling for mandatory that's government mandated
vaccination.
Now, I want to be really clear.
There is a huge difference between required
to do something and straight up compelled
vaccination.
In other words, we've had for a long time
vaccines that are required.
If you want to go to a certain college to
send your kid to a certain school, to work
in certain places, that wouldn't be new.
What people are now actually talking about
more seriously, some people that's not predominant
is the idea of government actually mandating
that people must be vaccinated, period.
You have to just get the vaccine, a government
mandated vaccine.
There's an op ed in The Washington Post by
Max Boot, who some people hate, called Stop
pleading with anti vaccines and start mandating
vaccinations.
Now, there are really two parts here.
First of all, is the question of would a mandatory
vaccine be legal now as a federal government
mandate?
There does not appear to be precedent for
that, that, you know, sometimes when we talk
about whether something would be legal, the
language should not be it doesn't seem like
it would be legal, but rather we're not able
to find precedent that that would be legal
at the state level.
The answer appears to be that, yes, state
government in many states could mandate vaccination.
You look at Jacobson v. Massachusetts from
nineteen five.
That was a Supreme Court case in which the
court upheld the authority of states to enforce
compulsory vaccination laws.
The court at the time articulated the view
that individual liberty is not absolute and
is subject to the police power of the state.
Quote, Massachusetts was one of only 11 states
that had compulsory vaccination laws.
Massachusetts law empowered the Board of Health
of individual cities and towns to enforce
mandatory free vaccinations for adults over
age 21.
If the municipality determined it was necessary
for the public health or safety of the community.
If you refused, you have to pay a five dollar
fine in nineteen two.
Faced with the outbreak of smallpox, the Board
of Health of the City of Cambridge adopted
a regulation ordering the vaccination or vaccination
of inhabitants, basically pointing out that
this is part of preserving liberty when there
is a public health imperative.
So legally, it's certainly conceivable that
states which wanted to make the covid vaccine
mandatory could do it.
Then you would get into questions like does
it apply to people who are legally residents
of the state?
What if you're traveling through?
What if you're temporarily working in a particular
state?
There's a ton of complexity.
That's not really the issue for me.
I am not actively for mandatory vaccination.
I'm for informing people and encouraging vaccination
in other ways.
But it would be political suicide to try to
make the covid vaccine mandatory.
Many of the people who don't want to get vaccinated
really don't want to get vaccinated.
And I believe it would be unmitigated political
disaster for anyone who tries to push mandatory
vaccination.
Now, one other thing in terms of the current
Supreme Court, my guess is that the current
court would only go with the precedent of
states being able to mandate vaccination.
And if and when these vaccines are fully approved
by the FDA.
My instinct is that if a state tried to do
this and there was a lawsuit and an appeal
and an appeal, and it eventually got to the
Supreme Court that the Supreme Court is not
going to uphold the precedent when it comes
to an emergency use authorization.
I just don't imagine that one idea I had which
I tweeted about was this is now other ways
to get people vaccinated.
I tweeted, If a rumor started that liberals
want to keep the vaccine away from conservatives
so that they die, would it make them get vaccinated
to own the Libs?
This is really childish reverse psychology,
but at the same time, it's this type of thing
that seems far more plausible and maybe even
more effective than a government mandated
vaccination.
I would be curious to hear from you.
We've been talking about this week what if
the vaccines were marketed as the Trump vaccine,
as Trump juice, as a freedom vaccine or whatever
the case may be?
Would that maybe get some of these people
to go out and get vaccinated when it comes
to mandatory vaccinations, even if you can
find legal precedent for it?
I don't think it's the way to go in particular
because the backlash and people who figure
out a way to avoid it anyway and the potential
politically suicidal aspect of it, it doesn't
seem like the way to go.
I want to hear from you, though.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman
and let me know your thoughts.
And also, we are approaching the 16th anniversary
of The David Pakman Show.
And to celebrate that, we will be doing a
one day membership special on Monday, August
16th.
It's not this month.
I got an email yesterday from someone saying,
David, sir, congratulations on 16 years.
I'm sorry, I'm a few days late.
They were actually a month early.
It is August 16th, technically the 17th, but
16th at midnight.
Anyway, you know how these things go.
We will be doing a huge email blast on the
16th telling you how to take advantage of
just an unconscionable membership discount.
Be notified by getting on my newsletter at
David Pakman Dotcom.
Remember that The David Pakman Show is mostly
sponsored and made possible by folks like
you, people who sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom,
we do a daily extra show every day.
We're done with the show.
We're toiling under the hot lights for hours.
And we do the show and then it's done.
And then we say, this can't be it.
We must do more.
And then we do an entire additional show for
our members.
So I invite you to sign up at Join Pakman
Dotcom